you've got some notes on peptides to use
for actually first before we talk about
peptides used for health and immunity
during during this pandemic situation
can you explain what peptides are
exactly
yeah so peptides are essentially
fractionated proteins
they're synthesized in a lab but i mean
they're naturally they're organic
they're naturally occurring but a
fractionated protein too
utilized to you know essentially
create a regenerative effect of
biological systems so what i mean by
that is you would use a peptide to
enhance
your natural
uh organic biological processes right so
there's a peptide out there that we can
talk about that enhances immunity right
what does that mean i mean well again it
will strengthen the things that your
body naturally does to
be resistant you know again to various
microbes pathogens germs whatever is you
know found in your environment
and um they're not i mean they're not
generally accepted this is like still
kind of fringe sort of medical
uh treatment it's mostly self-treatment
you know if anything i first came across
it um
i was in a men's group um you know the
mutual friend you know ben greenfield i
know you've talked quite a few times and
you've worked with them too um i
actually listened to the podcast that
you did with them that was that was a
really good one um and i was having some
knee problems and i you know reached out
to him like hey man you know what do you
recommend and he sent me this link to
this uh thing that was called a peptide
this is early on called bpc157 i know
you know what that is but sure um it's
it's it's great for your joints and
it's basically a water-based peptide
that you inject into your knee joint
area or any joint that you're you know
suffering uh pain or discomfort with
and it helps to regenerate uh connective
tissue and lubricate the joint and makes
it function properly and i stayed away
from it because it looks i mean it just
looks scary as hell you know putting
like you know little needles in your
joints and all that and when we got
together in uh california a few years
ago when i was in l.a um you know you're
like oh dude it's easy just grab the
skin right in here boom and i was like
okay i'm not gonna be a [ __ ] i'm not
gonna do it and it works and i was like
okay that was like two three years ago
and i was sold right and since then you
know i've i've used stuff like bpc1157
for joint injuries i've used tb500 um
i've used epitalon you know like once a
year to um
[Music]
i mean how would you define does it
strengthen or lengthen
yeah
yeah which which is supposed to lower
your biological age uh exactly and
there's scientific evidence that
confirms it too so so scientifically
yeah it does work and all these things
are
fairly effective you can't
trademark them from what i understand
which is probably why big pharma is not
fond of them and they try to get you on
their farmer products instead
um and they're quite safe because
they're
chains of proteins from what i
understand right exactly so um
talk about peptides for use with health
and immunity
and what people should look at and why
they should look at it
yeah so um so first off uh i i have to
say like everybody has
initially a injection phobia right it's
just a natural thing of like oh my god
i'm sticking my skin you know with a
needle whether depending regardless of
the size i mean everyone who's ever
injected themselves has that first
experience of like dude am i injecting
myself right like no matter how tough of
a dude you are you're like ah
but uh so it's funny that you say that
but i mean i can remember back when i
was like in my early 30s when i first
started my therapeutic testosterone and
i sat there for four hours like staring
at the needle like i can't do this i
can't do this i can't do this until my
original first wife just came up she
said sure you can't
chant it in me
did they give you like a one and a half
inch harpoon you know for the first time
no thankfully because that's what i got
yeah yeah well exactly and there you go
they're sick care they don't even
understand that but i i was actually
again at the very beginning for people
who followed me and know me you know i
was working with a a harvard
educated endocrinologist you know dr
raymond scruggs but anyway that's
another story for another day so
regarding peptides um
yes they are amazing
um
you know nick andrews my business
partner with a seer um is one of the
world's leading peptide experts i mean
he is an absolute genius you know you
talk to him about peptides you know he's
up there in the top two or three guys in
the world
and so i get a lot of my information
from him but also i have been using as
you know richard therapeutic peptides
before most people even knew what they
were you know before ben probably knew
what they were right i've been using
ipamarellan since 2006.
when they were literally like these
crazy research chemicals that people
didn't know what they were but back to
your point um
we're in a world today where we are
under siege
from every angle right we know that our
hormones our endocrine systems are
affected but also so is our health now
you know from whatever is being
engineered whether it's a bio weapon
whether it's a natural virus whatever it
is it doesn't matter whatever you're
feeling is you need to immunize yourself
and there are peptides that you can use
to dramatically enhance immunity now um
quick shell self shameless plug in about
a month and richard will be involved in
this
nick and i are launching a peptides
course and it will be the best peptides
course on earth
most people who want to use peptides who
watch shows like you and i are doing and
they get all excited because you know we
talk about what they do and you're right
dude bpc and tv 500 literally heal
severe injuries and like one tenth of
the time yeah they're i mean they're
they're basically golden age technology
and and i keep it in my fridge now like
all the time because if i get injured
it's like i don't have to wait to order
it it's there i just reconstitute it
with the bacteriostatic water boom the
injections in me within 10 minutes
i literally have
uh
breaking protocol i have a uh not a
grocery i have a refrigerator right over
here in the corner of my uh studio let
me guess a little bar fridge like a
small one i mean no it's a big one it's
not like you know a giant double door
but it's closed and my dog is like
literally guarding it my pit is like
right there at all he's i wish i could
take a picture of him right now because
he's all curled up and stuff but i have
ppc 157 tb 500 and the one i'm going to
talk about here in a second ta1 which is
time it's an alpha 1.
you know in a giant no i wouldn't call
it a jug but a big enough you know
reusable
deal so that if and when somebody i know
gets hurt you know i can i can attend to
them but
you know back to this
stuff most people listen to you and me
and people like us ben greenfield and
really smart people who talk about this
and then they go to buy it you know
you know we each rep these different
people out here online that sell
peptides and then they are like oh [ __ ]
yeah the vials have can't come they're
not they're not constituted
they don't explain about bacterial
static water they don't talk about
reconstitution they don't talk about
this that the other and so everybody
just is like flummoxed they're like what
do i say too much yeah yeah it's too
much so nick and i have created this
course which literally is going to be
the layman's guide on how to use
peptides it starts like okay you don't
know anything and that's why you're here
and here's where you do right so that's
going to really help a lot of people and
you and i will be involved in that you
know talking about that coming but
to add or to discuss what we're talking
about immunity so thymus and alpha 1 ta1
is a profound peptide that will enhance
your body's you know essentially
immunity against
exterior or excuse me external you know
agents viruses
bugs pathogens even stuff in your
stomach right you and i talk about
metformin we talk about guys you know
having weight issues i mean richard and
you know you know dr j
who's really big on this uh and you know
his latest research in the last year
he's i just talked to him recently
actually is that people have pesticides
in their fat
and they cannot
drop the weight bro like cardio and
growth hormone peptides or growth
hormone itself and fasting and all that
can't help them because
in the fat does dr anthony j have some
new material because um last time i had
them on was a couple years ago
after
yeah you got to get them back it was a
great conversation like i still get
emails from guys today like thanking me
for for having him on and recommending
the book like if you guys don't know who
dr anthony j is search my channel uh
there's at least an hour hour and a half
conversation i had with him and he
breaks and he breaks down all the
sources of environmental estrogens that
are um bombarding your body and throwing
off your opportunity to function in a in
a
properly you know like modern way you
know today because you're getting hit by
everything from every angle you know it
comes in food it comes you know and emf
it comes in uh
the water you drink it comes in
toiletries that you're putting on your
skin and on your body and in your body
and your mouth when you're brushing your
teeth
sunscreens everything sorry to sorry to
interrupt but character no no i'm glad
you said that because dr j is one of the
smartest people on the earth he's a
close personal friend of you and me i
love dr j by the way every time i talk
to him he's like dude richard cooper man
he really helped me yeah i know i got a
i got an email from him like six or
seven months ago he's like dude you're
the real dude
anytime you got some new stuff man let's
you know let's hook up no you definitely
need to reach out to him and bring it
back on but in our conversation just the
segway
he's like look man he's like people that
live in the midwest
where
the
fertilization stuff is in the
environment you know atrazine glyphosate
all that [ __ ] i mean like they have to
take massive precautions
to remain lean so again you know we we
talk in the united states of the flyover
country and how obesity is so rampant
but now i actually have even more
compassion for a lot of those people
because dude they're being deluged by
this crap that's in the environment and
again when it gets in your cells
it's really really difficult to get rid
of but thymus and alpha 1 back to the
peptide conversation if you use
microdoses of it now
you will be immune now when i say you
will be immune i also obviously i'm
talking about from a holistic standpoint
that you are doing the things that
richard and i recommend you know you're
living an insulin controlled lifestyle
you're hopefully optimizing your
hormones you're clearly exercising
you're lifting weights and you're doing
cardiovascular exercise but if you do
all those things and you use a micro
dose of thymus and alpha year round i
mean
the chances of you getting quote unquote
to see or whatever other [ __ ] they
unleash on us is very slim what does it
do exactly what does thymus and alpha do
because i haven't used that one yet
so i mean it you know it does a lot of
things right but you know when anything
that enhances immunity you know enhances
your body's like cells to
remain resistant without getting into
deeply esoteric conversation to remain
resistant to anything that can invade
you right now thymus and also alpha will
dramatically upregulate the acromancia
in the in the microbiome in the gut
right so again remember almost all
disease that people get starts in the in
the gut in the small intestine uh in the
microbiome from infections due to too
much alcohol too much sugar
which obviously all that over time leads
to body fat deposition and then body fat
deposition creates
cellular degradation
and ultimately inflammation as you know
inflammation is what causes disease so
any disease that anyone gets whether
it's type 2 diabetes heart disease any
of these things all are coming from the
cellular degradation which is leading to
inflammation so thymus and alpha is
going to be another protectant that's
going to upregulate your microbiome and
it's going to like create like a
cellular force field against pathogens
and invading microbes and stuff like
that
got it and where do people get it if
they want to get their hands on it and
how would they use it like is there
information provided when you buy it off
the website like how to reconstitute it
with dosages the frequency or is it
still under the guise of um
you know for research purposes only
so i always laugh because this is why
nick and i created this course right
answering thousands of emails you know
attempting to help guys so i mean again
i'll be the
jay campbell who's authentic and
transparent you can buy thymus and alpha
one at numerous
research chemical company manufacturers
you know
i'm sure you still do you know ben
greenfield i do you know we all will
push or affiliate for various guys and
people out there and if you're familiar
with my brand and go to my website
you'll see a box out of the people that
i promote
um but at the end of the day
you know those people
meaning research chemical companies
cannot legally tell you a how to use
them
and b you know you have to indemnify
yourself that you're using this for
research purposes with your laboratory
animal or whoever right so i'm just
going to put this in the chat the
spelling i just want to make sure i got
this right it's t-h-y-m-o-s-i-n
that's it yeah okay it's an alpha-1 it's
not spelling the shot if you guys want
t-t-a-1 so if you guys want to do your
own research or look it up again you
know this is like a research peptide
right
absolutely and but i will say just to
add to what you were saying is that
you know some of these because you you
mentioned something that's important
there are and again i could be wrong now
but at last count there was like six
therapeutic peptides that are
fda approved right and and again when
that when that means they're fda
approved that means a physician can
write them
quote-unquote
on label for various reasons that
they're approved and
there are also many peptides that
compound pharmacies especially in north
america
will sell to physicians that physicians
can write a script for that are
essentially you know not indicated or
you know not specifically for a
diagnosis again a doctor a legal a
doctor has a legal right to write that
prescription for you so
it's still though as you said a very
gray area the largest compounding
pharmacy
selling uh peptides and again you know i
know the owner of this company very well
i won't mention their names and stuff
but they did a lot of good for a lot of
people in humanity for about four or
five years and then the fda just said oh
no you're not going to do this you know
you're selling too many of these and
you're doing this like in a way that we
don't find
in a way that is right and you know
again i won't get into politics of it
but
at the end of the day peptides are the
future of medicine and there's even as
you know richard and we're not going to
talk about it we'll talk on another show
about it but there are even things
called bioregulators
that the russians have patents on that
are even as good if not better than
peptides i mean like there are there's a
bioregulator out there right now that
can regenerate heart tissue
so i mean there's amazing like i said
golden age stuff but for now if you want
to be a guy who follows jay campbell or
richard cooper
you know your peptides are your best
option to get stuff that can
dramatically improve your physique and
obviously augment all sorts of other
things all right let's let's um let's
start moving on to the hair and skin
stuff but before we do i got a super
chat here from justin he's asking about
are there any cons to ti1
um so that's a good question justin oh
jesse i'm sorry um the reality of all
peptides is like anything and richard
and i have said this many times on
podcast is that the difference between a
pill
and a poison is the dosage okay so
anything that you would use you know
from even aspirin you know that you buy
at a pharmacy
uh versus a peptide is going to be
relative to how much you use i mean you
know so is there a risk if you like you
know overdose on thymus and alpha one
unlikely that there's anything that's
gonna do something to you but i always
say that with the caveat that like you
know intelligent use
determines whether or not you're ever
gonna have any side effects but uh
thymus and also one is heavily studied
in mega dosages and there are very very
few if known side effects
okay
you